So now, that you know how
individual UI elements are sized.
Let's talk about how to start
arranging them together.
Let's have a quick refresher on what you
learned in Android Fundamentals 1 about
the core layout managers.
Like frame layout, linear layout,
and relative layout.
Now, remember a frame layout
arranges the views inside it,
one on top of each other and
each view can have a gravity or
stretch to fill the width or
height of the parent frame layout.
So frame layouts are a great way
to display overlapping content.
A linear layout arranges its
children in a single direction.
For example,
a vertical linear layout arranges
its children from top to bottom.
Linear layout is one of the most useful
layouts to have in your toolbox.
You can create pretty
much any layout with it.
Be careful though not to over rely
on this as another layout might be
more efficient way to
create the desired effect.
A relative layout arranges its chart
views relative to each other or
to its bounds.
So for example,
a field can align to the top left or
top right or to the bottom
edge of the relative layout.
While a relative layout can be powerful,
it also has some
performance implications.
So be weary of using this layout
especially near the root of your
hierarchy.
A GridLayout arranges
children in a grid, shocker.
When each child has a given row or
column within that grid, they can be
arranged automatically in any direction.
And now, have a weight property
in order to fill a column or row.
GridLayout is a great way if you want
to align content along multiple axes,
such as vertically and
horizontally at the same time in a grid
which you would be hard to achieve with
a different nested layout manager.
A ScrollView is a very simple view
which holds one single child.
It allows you to scroll its contents,
either up or down.
In under fundamentals,
we also touched on ListView and
its newer cousins RecyclerView and
ViewPager and how it dynamically uses
a small number of child views to present
a small window into a larger collection.
ListView and RecyclerView let you
scroll through a list of items,
while ViewPager let's you horizontally
page through individual items.
To understand when to use a particular
view group, let's take a look at some
examples of real world screens and
talk about how you would build them.
After that, we'll show you a quiz and
ask you, yes you, to apply layouts
to build up a relatively complex UI.